just two out of five high speed trains
are running across France on Christmas
Eve one of the busiest travel periods of
the year but with a nationwide transport
strike now in its third week many
travelers used to the disruption seemed
to have found a workaround Paris's
garden or was busy but not chaotic
people are tired I think it's it's we're
ready for it to be over but again it's I
mean I'm sure the other side who can
understand you know the reason for the
strike and everything I've been looking
for a way to get to my destination for
an hour now and I still haven't been
able to find an alternative so it's yeah
my journey was disrupting the National
rail operator SNCF will only guarantee
travel for those who booked tickets in
advance and even they may not have a
seat the SNCF says the strike is costing
it 22 million dollars a day in lost
revenue in 1995 after three weeks of
public sector strikes in the run-up to
Christmas the government caved in and
shelved plans to reform Frances pension
and welfare system there's no indication
so far that the government will perform
a similar retreat this time there seems
to be no end in sight to these transport
strikes but government and the unions
will meet again in the second week of
January but that's when there will also
be another round of nationwide
demonstrations Burnett Smith al Jazeera
Paris